this is what i was kind of picturing me
too or that we do like back like back to
back to back like the the classic lethal
weapon yeah yeah yeah but in our in our
underwear so i thought like twitchies
would be touching you know just you know
give something to that's what i'm saying
and then they chose to put they put us
in all those the clothes and we're like
just sitting eating popcorn eating
popcorn
pete davidson and machine gun kelly
stripped down to their underwear on
instagram live
it's hard to top that one man on monday
the 28 year old saturday night live star
teamed up with his pal mgk to take over
calvin klein's account
do not use the bathroom down here at
club
no you're in the way how do you uh how
do you go live i don't have instagram
dude we don't have to go live yet move
you're in the way what just
is there a button what do you just do
you click the live it literally sounds
like you're you're on live now idiot
okay
it all started when pete who doesn't
have an insta account of his own first
posted a selfie on the designer's grid
writing quote i got instagram mgk hit up
the comments and asked are you gonna
post us in our undies and folks that's
just what they did
what a way to bounce back after joking
that calvin klein didn't ask them to
pose in their underwear i thought that
was they were going to be like look
sexy idiots but for now man we're just
idiots they gave us popcorn and
video games like i have like mad good
poses and stuff like did you practice
your poses i had like a yeah yeah i had
like man all right well i mean you wanna
see my pose yeah yeah and that's when
pete stripped down and busted out some
pretty impressive poses i was gonna be
like you know obviously
fluff up the boys yeah for sure yeah
stuff a banana or you know and i was
just kidding socks you know i was doing
oh you were going for the latest
you know just kind of like uh yeah
that's right and mgk he had some ideas
of his own if you're laying on i should
be standing like a whole like well we're
not going to be like laying on top of
each other no no that's what i'm saying
i would be so i'd be standing right and
and you'd be here and i'd be like
like
pouring milk on you or something right
yeah
yeah okay
but that wasn't the only prep the guys
said they did
when we first got the call that we were
gonna do calvin klein we were both so
excited we were like yo we're gonna get
buff yeah like i didn't eat
for like two weeks i actually i got a i
got a parasite
it's still it's still in my stomach i
have to go get it removed i did let the
abs of steel work out every day for two
weeks straight well instead of an
underwear ad fans got this insta live i
just think we could have like really
crushed the underwear game like that's
what i was thinking
big missed opportunity and pete joked
that it was a big mistake i totally see
you as an underwear model yeah you too
bro thank you yeah for sure you know and
it just would have been so cool because
they're so used to just like safe
safe people you know where you're just
like oh yeah and then they would have
saw us they would
you know we could have got all like the
dirty people to buy underwear
you know like dirty trash like our fans
of course this isn't the first time the
two have collaborated on a project
together pete actually starred in mgk's
2018 music video for his track loco
hated the most so i keep my haters close
let them know i want to smoke so much
bread i gotta boast this burner turn you
into toast
and last month at the american music
awards mgk proved he's got pete's back
because when he was asked about his
pal's budding romance with kim
kardashian his lips were sealed gotta
ask you your boy pete davidson and kim
kardashian how happy are you for him
but we're happy yeah yeah
a source recently told et that the kkw
beauty founder and the king of staten
island star are pretty into each other
adding that pete is a romantic who goes
out of his way to make him feel special
and they've been connecting on a deeper
level i love that but back to pete and
machine gun kelly to send you off here
are the besties posing in their undies
one last time
should we do it together i mean yeah
yeah okay
all right
one of these all right i'll do it
yeah you do like one of those like uh
like did you do these like
i didn't know i was in my underwear
and i'd do something like this like
you know just get get all the
get all the people going
anyways
that's that's what i was thinking
[Music]
you